i am breaking the rules with my very
first question because i'm posing it to
both of you
i always love talking about the value of
having a good scene partner and you two
have so many super emotional
conversation driven scenes together in
the show so what is something that the
other did for you in those moments that
you really appreciated and maybe brought
something out of you that you couldn't
bring out yourself i want to take this
one first um zach and i
work in very different ways i am very
very like up front with my insecurities
i'm very theater girl i'm very cerebral
and zack is very
pay me i'm gonna show up and say the
words that are written on the page
and so i would sometimes get in my head
and and turn to zach for like
affirmation that like art is the most
important thing and i truly expressing
my art and zach would be like just say
the words kate just just be here you're
fine you're fine you're fine and i think
without that those days would have been
a lot longer
yeah i'll speak to that um
in that i think what kate brings to
every scene and it made those scenes
i don't wanna say easy to do but like
she listens like
it just makes you feel like someone's
listening to you and when you're
going on and on about death or about
whatever um and it makes you want to
listen to them as well uh and she's just
so present and so yeah we have very
different styles you know i know she
would
um have a backstory for every every
piece of clothing she was wearing and
she'd be like what about your sweater
i'd be like it was in my trailer
tell me
put it on so i
guess this is what riley wears um
and uh
but within all that like our different
ways of coming to it um i think you know
she was a lot of fun to work with
because like all you can ask for in a
scene partner is to listen to you and to
be there and um she
she really was and she did that for me
like i i really am forever grateful and
um you know because i had to do a
chemistry read with her she already had
the part i was trying to win the part um
she claims that the part was mine to
lose which may or may not be true
however i would have said it to everyone
yeah but i've had chemistry with people
where you're like dude you already have
this job like and you're
um so she was so giving from that moment
when we were strangers
um
and uh
yeah it was really cool
it was it was fun i had a lot of fun
working with it i think it's hard at a
certain point it's hard to describe what
it is and i guess that's what chemistry
is right that
on paper
zach and i work in different ways but on
the day
it was easy we made it easy for each
other to go to the places we needed to
go i always laugh when people are like
okay we're gonna have you do a chemistry
read i'm like i'm gonna clearly i'm
gonna like pretend to get along with
this person great like
and and that's why sometimes when you
have a bad chemistry you're like what is
this person what is wrong with this
person and i'm like sitting there trying
to be like no you're awesome you're
great
yeah and you're just like a jerk and
you're like what
okay i don't know why
yeah it's true it's true but zach i feel
like would have chemistry with a potted
plant he's just that kind of giving
loving person i have no chemistry with
potted plants i kill them all so i envy
me too no all right so kate thanks for
the compliment but you're right so many
murderers here not not with purpose i
swear i want to follow up on one thing
zach brought up for you kade what is a
seemingly insignificant little detail
even if it is a part of her wardrobe
that you came up with a backstory for
that no one's gonna find out but was
important to you oh yeah in erin's house
there is a uh like a white board next to
her phone and there's a note that says
call jim and i literally spent 20
minutes like who the [ __ ] is jim
who's call is that my mom's no do i need
to call a gym there's no gym on this
[ __ ] island and i was wandering
around set asking people who jim was
until mike literally was like please go
back to your room you're making
everybody wear ppe all the time so you
can find out who jim is and i was like
all right jim's the plumber i get it
okay that makes sense i believe in that
um
zach this this question might be coming
from the fact that i've seen two really
intense hamish performances back to back
now but
what is it like being yelled at by him
on set in particular in episode 5 when
he's just screaming how does it make you
feel just as a viewer i am scared for
you as an
actor um you know
you're like when i was in that moment
you're a little like this dude's crazy
like he's crazy
and you're a little like
what like this guy believes in angels
and what like
he just sucked my blood and he's talking
about like
and i it doesn't really show in the
scene but i the whole time i'm looking
for an exit
i'm just like
what can i get out of there can i get
out over there because i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here
um
so it's yeah and hamish is amazing it's
kind of funny too because hamish and i
were friends before this project
um
so it's kind of it which is so fun
because like kate and hamish were my two
like main
scene partners
uh
and it's so different with each of them
in great ways and you're clearly playing
different characters and i didn't know
kate before
but we had the more intimate stuff and
hamish i knew really well but we had
this thing where we were supposed to not
know each other so it just was kind of
like an interesting
dynamic um
but a lot of fun he's yeah he's a lot of
fun to work with he's an
amazing actor when i found out that he
was doing the part
i was like that's genius like i can't
imagine anyone else in this part it
would be so boring
no offense to mike
but no those families were riveting just
yeah that yeah when you were sitting
there listening to those monologues in
person those homilies in person it's it
was exactly as exciting as it is on
camera
this and that other project i was
referencing it's it's the type of
scenario where he is just next level and
nobody else could play the role that way
except him he is mind-blowing in those
things in particular but pretty much
everything i've ever seen even
let's talk about that boat scene now
kate knows i i like to harp on this one
because it's it's incredible
zach i'm curious about your
conversations with mike in terms of
figuring out exactly what drove riley to
make the decision to go out that way was
there ever a point where he considered
fighting uh was there was there ever a
point where he considered
not necessarily putting aaron in that
situation how did you kind of land on
where you did in the final product you
know uh
well mike and i didn't have any
conversations about it i kind of the way
i come to things are
um
it's already on the page this is what
we're doing
and
i'm only gonna have the conversation if
it doesn't make sense to me
and it made sense to me you know
given the world we're in and the person
that aaron is the person the riley is he
knows like look i'm gonna what am i
gonna run around being a vampire for the
rest of my life no um and the only way
i'm going to be able to con vince ryan
aaron is
if she sees it like she hasn't like no
one's ever gonna believe this unless
they see it so it's just kind of like
look i'm gonna this is gonna happen
i i hate to like traumatize her but the
only way she'll ever maybe
um take my advice and just row to the
other shore is if she sees it
so yeah i think it's just on the page it
made sense i bought it
and so
which makes it so much easier as an
actor because you're like okay i believe
this so i can go and pretend this
there's one other layer to that i really
wanted to ask you about it's it's the
idea of him having had that vision
for so so long and then actually finding
himself in the middle of it but then
discovering that someone else is in it
with him what do you think that meant to
him
um
i think it meant it just kind of like
um
validated that this is the choice it's
like my subconscious like i've been
you know he's not someone who really
would believe that people can see the
future or whatever
but it just kind of validates like yeah
this is what i have to do like my
subconscious has been telling me this
it's been forecasting this um
so as someone who no longer believes in
god or a higher power
whatever there is it's telling me this
is what i have to do and it's been
hinting at it for a while
i have to let you guys go i've already
been greedy and had so much time but i
could talk about this show all day long
huge congratulations thank you guys for
uh for talking to us today nice thank
you barry